last time you were here you were talking
about the NFL and how Goodell said we
didn't get it right oh yeah right
you know and the whole Ray Rice the
whole Ray Rice thing do you think
they've done a better job since I mean
I'm not on the inside but I can tell you
as a football fan those no more
commercials are driving me up the wall
it's like I'm sitting down watching a
game and all of a sudden I start getting
reprimanded like I know a woman that's
getting beaten and I'm not saying
anything it's like wait a minute I
didn't do this you guys did this look
turn this around on me
you NFL should be watching this
commercial why are you showing this to
me like I did it I didn't do this it is
the whole thing is nuts
those are those ads the ads are other
players no more she slipped on an Afghan
and banged her head off a pencil
sharpener ah no more of that yeah now
all of that in sports it's driving me
nuts because what I love about sports is
it's a great way to tap out from the
news and just you know watch a game and
get away from it now there's like all
these causes are getting like attached
to it like I was watching the World
Series and I'm in the middle of watching
the World Series and out of nowhere they
have this moment stand up to cancer I'm
watching a ballgame and all of a sudden
everybody stands up holding up a sign of
somebody that they either know that's
dying of cancer or died of it in the
middle of the game it's just like what
are you doing trying to watch a game
here well there's a time and a place
well I know sorry
I know somebody that has died of cancer
I would never go to the movies with you
and in the middle of it hit pause to be
I oh by the way Carnot I could have
lifted him up off the sheet with two
fingers it was horrible hey and Joe oh
by the way I got molested when I was
nine so like are we not aware of cancer
we're aware of it we know it we know
it's bad I get it right I will help but
can I just watch a game without YouTube
well just in case you know you forgot
about the horrors of the world for half
a second you know they just you just cut
to like an earthquake and people getting
buried in a mudslide like it's the next
pictures warming up I didn't know have
you been to any games lately I'm trying
to picture you at a game what's the
latest game you went to this game oh I
went to once a year I do the road I have
a good time when I go on the road I'm a
big big sports fan so I went to college
football game I go to a big college
football game rivalry game every year
this year I went to University of Miami
versa Florida State and and I had a
great time insane fans but uh you know I
made sure that when I saw Florida State
it was an away game because I actually
liked Florida State but that Tomahawk
Chop thing drives me nuts it has nothing
to even do with the Native American
thing it's the fact that they do it
every like three seconds they form a
huddle and all of a sudden the band
starts playing everything the crowds
like and they never get sick of it it's
like the band knows one song it's like I
got it it was funny you know what's
funny about that is you know like Native
Americans never even did that you know
like white people came up with that
in like the 1920s when they were making
like they first got sound in movies like
what did they sound like I don't know
they've got some morons on this set also
just put some Rouge on his face how do
you don't know I know no and even if I
was the biggest Florida State fan ever
like even like halfway through the
fourth quarter I'm tapping out it's like
these can we get another song going here
yeah something I know I think I made the
point yeah
[Laughter]
you